there's an interesting sort of side
story going on with Democratic
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard who is
running for the Democratic presidential
nomination she's currently polling about
1 percent which is that she may actually
lose her congressional reelection
campaign and be removed from Congress
altogether in November of 2020 and part
of what suggests that is that these
races most races in American politics
quite frankly they depend heavily on
money in the political system that we
have and while Tulsi is running for
president she has a challenger in Hawaii
who's actually out fundraising her the
person running against Tulsi is Hawaii
State Senator Kai hailey who has raised
more than three hundred and forty five
thousand dollars so far this is nearly
50% more than Tulsi gabbard's
two hundred and twenty one thousand
raised during the same time period now
there are a few interesting elements to
this number one earlier this week I
already discussed with you that Tulsi
Gabbard received a gift over the weekend
which is that in a campaign that was
very clearly winding down and going
nowhere with Tulsi Gabbard not even on
every debate stage not qualifying for
the third debate Hillary Clinton was
accused of suggesting that Tulsi Gabbard
is a Russian asset although now the
original reports of that by the New York
Times have been modified in any case
that's a different story the credibility
of the story it was a huge boost to
Tulsi Gabbard and she is getting more
attention now but at the same time she
is up for re-election her term in the
United States Congress representing
Hawaii every two years is up for
election and she has an opponent now
there are many states in the US where
you're not even allowed to run for
president while you are also running for
Congress Hawaii allows it and Tulsi
Gabbard can run simultaneously for
re-election in the house and for the
Democratic presidential nomination but
it's not totally clear if she's really
still running for re-election in Hawaii
she's almost stopped fundraising locally
over the last several
for the congressional campaign and
interestingly her opponent kaika Haley
has been focusing on how Tulsi has been
distracted by running for president both
from running for re-election but he
makes the case from her duties as a
member of the House of Representatives
pointing out that she missed an
important vote on Syria last week that
she's not spending much time in the
district at all and this is a typical
case that is often made against elected
officials who were going and running for
higher office now there's a ton of
speculation that Tulsi doesn't really
want to stay in the House of
Representatives and that once she drops
out of the presidential race she may
actually just formally say I am NOT
going to run for re-election in the
House of Representatives this is
actually a strategy that some
politicians use when they want to leave
a position they run for higher office
that they know they can't win and then
they say well listen I've put my energy
into that I'm not going to run for
re-election or whatever the case may be
I actually know some people doing this
at the local local to state level in a
couple different parts of the country I
don't know if that's actually tell C's
plan I have no idea now on the merits
kaika hailey actually seems like a
pretty good choice to represent Hawaii
in Washington DC he supports Medicare
for all period like I don't need to
qualify it in any other way I don't need
to play around with words like
affordability and choice and access and
all the stuff which are often used to
not say I am for Medicare for all period
as far as Tulsi is concerned I think
she's going to do just great I think she
can easily line up a gig for example as
a fox news contributor after she fails
to secure the Democratic nomination I
could see her brought onto Fox News as a
contributor that is a Democrat that the
right can feel good about while still
calling themselves fair and balanced but
not really stepping outside of their
comfort zone sort of like that guy Juan
Williams that has been a longtime Fox
News contributor unclear whether she'll
have to dye her hair blonde before Fox
will hire her but
remains to be seen she could do lobbying
I mean there's many possibilities for
Tulsi I think she's going to do just
fine if she loses and then ultimately
withdraws from her Hawaii campaign where
do you believe Tulsi Gabbard will be a
year from now let me know if you believe
she will be President of the United
States well that wouldn't be a year from
now that'd be a year in a few months I I
disagree with you I can tell you in
advance but I'm curious to see how many
people in the audience think that she is
ripe for a Fox News contributor ship I
am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com
forward slash PA k ma n